مثلا ادفيه مثلا خالاتي يقعدون يتكلمون
على الالوان
تطلع مصطلحات غريبه تفاحي ركوازي مدري ايش
تركس ثاني
انا عبد الرحمن عبد الكريم الشبران طالب
سنه رابعه ممكن كثير من الناس يعني عندهم
تعريف خاطره
عمل الوان هو خلاص المصاب فيه شوف ابيض
واسود عمل الوان فيه اكثر من نوع في عمل
الوان اللون الاخضر يعمل الوان اللون
الاحمر في الازرق مثلا واحد قاعد يلعب في
الكاس المدرسه اقول والله اللي لابس اخضر
يعرف يلعب مش ما في احد لابس اخضر وين
تشوف يعني اني خلاص ما عاد اوصف لون واقول
هذا طويل يعرف يلعب ما عاد يقول لابس اخضر
انا اللي فيني عمى اخضر تحط لون بني جنب
لون اخضر جنب لون اخضر غامق هنا ما راح
اقدر افرق بين الثلاثه يعني
كان مجلس مع امي
على الالوان ويشرون على الاشياء ويسالوني
هذا وش تشوفه والله انا اشوفه مني ينظرون
فيني طيب هذا
نفس ذاك اليوم سويت الاختبار جبت اخواني
تسووا الاختبار دخلت عليهم بعد ما اكتشفتم
فيني قال لي صديقي يعني راح العيال خالتك
90% تلقاه عندهم يعني الوان ما رحت لهم
فعلا دخلت عليهم قلت لهم سوى هذا الاختبار
ما في ارقام ما يشوفون ارقام زيي
ونسبه 95% وخواتك
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه لي مو بشيء معيق مره غيري ممكن
يشوفها شيء معيق اكثر مثلا واحد من ايام
المتوسط من ايام الثانوي حلم انه يكون
طيار حربي فجاه انه ما يقدر يدخل الطيران
حربي بسبت هذا الشيء يمكن يشوفها شيء يعني
دمر حياته لكن بالنسبه لي انا
تخصص اللي يعني ابغاه اللي كنت ابغاه يعني
من زمان اللي هو الطب
وما كان يطلب في تخصصات يعني داخل الطب زي
مثلا طب الجلديه طب العيون هذه ممكن يعني
اللي عندي عمل الوان صعب علي يدرسها وصعب
عليه انه يمارسها يعني او يتخصص فيها
[موسيقى]
زملائي يعني مثلا في الطب يعرفون مش عامل
الوان يعرفون ان لها انواع يعرفون يعني
اذا قلت لاحد فيهم كذا تكون رده فعله شويه
حلوه يعني غير عن احد مثلا في مجلس
في مكان ما اعرفه مثلا يعرف ان عندي عمل
الوان رده فعله تكون غريبه وشو عامل الوان
يبدا يحط لك خمسه اشياء يلا هذا وشلونه
هذا وشلونه واذا ما عرفتي ابدئي ليش ما
تعرف ليش وش ما تشوف ليه طيب وريني
الاختبار يمكن يطلع فيني انا بعد املان
اول ما عرفت كنت متحمسك اقول للناس عنه
لكن الحين شوي يطفى الحماس ايوه كذا عمل
الوان ثلاث انواع خلاص اخبر واحمر وازرق
وانا فيني اخضر وخلاص
[موسيقى]
في الجوال فيه اغلب الالعاب عندها يعني في
الاعدادات خيار المصابين بعمل الوان اقرب
مثال لعبه كول اوف ديوتي كان في اللي هو
الشات اللي تحت على اليمين اقدر اختاره حق
الفريق حقي بس عشان
اللي ضدي واللي معي كلهم اما كنت اقدر
افرق باللون
يوم غيرت لو فعلت الخيار حق عمل الالوان
بدا يوضح لي اكثر
مخليين حق الفريق لحاله اخضر خلينا حق
الفريق الفريق مع بعض برتقالي مكان في
صعوبه يعني اني افرق بينهم ان هذا يكلمني
ولا يكلم اللي معه هذا يكلمني ولا يكلم
اخوياي
مره البس لبس
اني انا اخترت بنفسي
طلعت فيه على امي اول كلمه ضحى ضحكت قعدت
تناظرني من فوق لتحت
كلش هذا
يعني
تداخل الوان غير طبيعيه يعني من بعد ذاك
الموقف تقريبا اقل اعتماد على نفسي
بالملابس اكثر صارت الوالده هي اللي تشتري
لي اكثر اذا بغيت اشتري لنفسي انا محدود
تقريبا كم لون يوم ابيض اسود ايش يعني
يعني اضمن نفسي فيها
من حصه الفنيه كانت اسوا حصه المدرسه اولا
لاني ما اعرف ارسم ثانيا لان
اذا ارسلت ما عاد اعرفه يمكن في مدرسين
يعني يفهموا الموضوع يعني عرفوا عندي
صعوبه مع الراس وخلاص يعني صار ما يشد علي
لكن في مدرسين ثانيين لا يشدون وكانت في
صعوبات كنت اقرا الحصه كبرة يعني
[موسيقى]
كانت تسبب لي احباط ان اللون هذا ما اقدر
اشوفه او عندي مشكله معه وباقي الناس يعني
يقدرون يصفونه ويتكلمون عنه بشكل عادي
زي ما قلت ان المشكله داخليه اكثر منها
يعني تطلع للناس يعني جوه نفسي اقول ليش
انا ما اشوف زي باقي الناس ليش بالذات كذا
اللون هذا ما اقدر اشوفه ليش باقي الالوان
عادي
في عصر رقمي متغير باستمرار المواكبه هي
اساس النجاح ولاننا رواد المستقبل الرقمي
نوظف خبراتنا وقدراتنا لنمكن نبتكر نبدع
في تبني احدث التقنيات وتوفير الحلول
بكفاءه وذكاء
[موسيقى]
كان شعور يعني كنت كانت العدسه كذا انزلها
ما في رقم ارفعها في رقم يعني كان شعور
شوي حلو وشوي حلو بنفس الوقت يعني ليش ما
اقدر اشوفها بدون العدسه انا اللي كان
عندي او اللي عندي حاليا شديد يعني
الاختبار تقريبا في اثنين من 17
يعني قدرت اشوف رقمين
من 17 رقمها يعتبر شيء شديد يعني
[موسيقى]
في رقم اصلا
هذه ثلاثه
ثمانيه